hi there today I want to talk about
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and in particular with the
rapidly changing state of the art what
is easy
what's medium and what's really hard
today with with machine learning and
artificial intelligence what is likely
to change in the future where were we
just a few years ago so that's what I'm
going to talk about today
ok so machine learning easy medium and
hard now across nearly every discipline
both in terms of scientific research
industry and in our everyday lives
machine learning is is redefining the
art of what is possible and even what we
thought was possible five years ago is
getting redefined now with tremendous
advances okay so these are driven by
rapidly increasing volumes of data so
for example Google Images is this vast
amount of data on naturalistic images
the Facebook database is a tremendous
you know database of millions and
millions of human faces from different
angles and different perspectives you
have surveillance cameras you know
Google searches so the amount of data is
growing at an incredible rate in
addition you have faster and faster
computers parallel architectures like
GPUs better data storage so cheaper hard
drives and memory and faster transfer
and so you you have this kind of
culmination of big volumes of data and
hardware that can handle those those big
volumes of data and in the middle you
have advancing and emerging mathematical
techniques kind of applied math
statistics being developed in many
different disciplines these algorithms
are essentially mining features from
this big data and allowing allowing you
to essentially pull out relevant
information coherent patterns and
actionable information and so these kind
of three things together so big data big
computers and you know better sharper
tools algorithms
are really driving this field forward an
incredible rate okay so that's what
we're going to talk about and this is
going to be just through a couple of
case studies so what is actually
possible in examples and I really like
this xkcd comic so I'm going to put
links to as much of this as possible so
you can go find these links and and dig
in
this is an xkcd comic I really like so
I'll let you read it for a minute so I
think this is kind of fun because it
really is easy in the modern era to
think of machine learning is almost like
a magic wand
okay so or a black box right you put in
data you get out awesome predictions and
results or you know you hire someone and
you say okay I want machine learning to
solve all my problems go and so really
it's easy to set up problems that are
trivial with data science so telling if
a picture is taken in a national park is
just a matter you know photos are tagged
with location but figuring out if the
photo has a bird in it much much harder
right you need a research team in five
years now it's funny this was actually
this comic is from a number of years ago
when this was actually hard now with the
the incredible pace of progress in image
classification this is basically a
solved task by many research teams
across the world okay so this also
illustrates that what used to be very
hard and need a research team in five
years what used to be very hard is now
essentially you know trivial okay so
facial recognition is a huge one what I
always tell my students is you know in
my collaborators if if you can take your
data and make it look like an image then
you get decades of incredible research
and algorithms for free because image
recognition face recognition has been
one of the cornerstones of machine
learning you know machine vision for
decades and a lot of the most powerful
algorithms are developed for for mining
and classifying and making decisions
based on images so here you see a selfie
this was a picture that that Ellen took
with a bunch of celebrities and some
some researchers essentially used the
Viola Jones facial detector algorithm to
automatically pull out all of the
regions in the image that it thought
were faces and then you can use a face
detector algorithm to tell who these
faces are with pretty high accuracy okay
so for example I think the face book
facial recognition algorithm of who is
who so not just putting boxes around
faces but telling telling the user who
the people actually are is now
approaching human accuracy in terms of
classification which is quite quite
impressive right this is taking decades
for algorithms to get as good as humans
at telling who belongs to what face but
now they're able to do it and fun fact
one of the ways that they actually do
this that image recognition and facial
recognition algorithms actually do this
and reach that human level performance
so for a long time they were stuck a few
percentage points below humans in
accuracy and essentially what what
bridged this gap at least one of the the
technologies was estimating what is the
actual skeletal structure what's the
three-dimensional structure of the face
from this 2d image so as a human I have
all of this experience walking around
the world in three dimensions and seeing
people from different perspectives so
it's very easy for me to estimate the
depths of a cheek or a nose or how deep
you know someone's someone's eyes are
behind their you know their forehead and
so that's the kind of technology now
computers from these 2d images are able
to estimate that that skeletal
reconstruction and then that gives them
enough information for that human level
performance okay so this is a problem
people have been working on for decades
now I mean I don't want to say it's
completely solved but you know everyone
holds up their phone and you know
there's a number of people your phone
automatically puts boxes around all
those people's faces so that's using
very similar technology which is very
likely based on the viola Jones
algorithm okay so a lot of image
recognition so image classification used
to be a kind of a
and challenge machine learning and
machine vision problem and then I think
in 2012 this this landmark data set this
image net data set was curated and put
online for all of the world to try to
develop and test their machine learning
algorithms to classify different images
so this is just a tiny tiny slice of
these millions and millions of images
that were labeled okay so these are
labeled images where you know you know
what is actually in the image so if i
zoom in on a little region here you can
see there's there's everything okay
there's you know a picture of an iPod
and a person with some headband and you
know I mean there's there's every
picture you can imagine and they're all
labeled
and so this massive volume of training
data along with the massive increase in
computer power and GPUs and deep neural
nets it made this kind of quantum leap
in performance of image classification
so this was the landmark data set and
also demonstration of deep learning
where it really got back on the map so
people have been using neural networks
for forever for decades but having this
wealth of labeled data so this is called
supervised classification when you have
labeled data so someone's telling you
what is what and then you're learning
that and that was really kind of this
this massive change in the performance
of deep learning that that really
started it off on this exponential
trajectory and you know it's undeniable
that deep learning has essentially
improved you know almost every field
it's been it's been applied to where
there is this kind of wealth of data of
labeled data so it's really changing
what's possible in terms of performance
metrics in many many tasks now the
caveat is you need a tremendous amount
of training data so lots of times we
want to learn with minimal amounts of
data that's still quite hard you know
humans and biological systems are
experts at one shot or two shot learning
where you have a few trials of
information and you can adaptively learn
that very quickly because you have this
experiential framework to hang that
information but computers are getting
better when you have
this volumes of data so this used to be
kind of a grand challenge hard problem
now this is kind of the base level entry
level so now this is kind of an easy
problem because we have big enough
computers and big enough data sets so
image classification is doable now this
is just kind of an example of how rich
this imagenet data set is so nearly
everything you can think of so these are
like tractor-trailer or sorry these are
these are harvesters right like John
Deere trucks these are pictures of
broccoli these are some purple flowers
pretty much anything you can think of
there are dozens if not hundreds of
examples of these of these images in
this image net training set and so to
some extent your anything you will see
in the future you are likely to have
seen something similar to it in this
training data so that's also one of the
catches with this this deep learning is
oftentimes we think of it as like a
really fancy interpolation but you have
enough richness of the training data
that anything in the future you'll see
can kind of be interpolated based on
what you've seen in the past and this is
this nonlinear hierarchical interpreted
interpolation now this is an interesting
I'm pulling this this picture from this
great paper in cvpr 2017 I encourage you
to go read it
the first time that I I downloaded and
use this image I didn't even realize
this second column here or maybe this
fourth column these are actually
artificially generated images by the
deep learning algorithm so these are
called gans generative adversarial
networks where essentially you have one
part of the network that's trying to
tell is this a real image of a purple
flower is this a real image of a
harvester and then you have another
network which is kind of trying to
generate images to trick your classifier
into thinking that it generated a purple
flower or a tractor so they're kind of
adversarially training against each
other you have a classifier kind of the
traditional image net classifier and
then you have this this generative
network that's trying to trick it and so
remarkably I mean if you look very
closely you can see that these are kind
of just make-believe images this is
really broccoli this is just green blobs
in a statistical pattern that looks a
heck of a lot like broccoli from where
I'm standing and similarly with these
with these harvesters so what's really
really interesting is now actually
generating fake images that can trick a
trained classifier this totally fooled
me the first time the first several
times that's how good these fake
broccoli images are they look just like
broccoli these purple flowers are even
better and so these these Gans are
getting amazing at at kind of faking
these these naturalistic images and
they're even getting to the point where
you can fake videos so this is becoming
a big kind of social hot topic right now
because what if I can fake a video of a
world leader saying something either
offensive about another country or you
know sabre-rattling like what if I can
actually fake a video of a politician
and and trick another country into
thinking that it was really our leader
or another country's leader so there's
this kind of misinformation potential
when you can fake images and fake videos
that's really quite worrisome and it's
it's progressing at a rate that we kind
of I don't think anybody saw this coming
how fast we were gonna be able to fake
videos I mean this is this is science
fiction technology that's now pretty
much possible if you have enough enough
training data ok so very interesting
interesting topic now image
classification is not I don't want to
make it sound like it's it's completely
done there are still things that humans
are able to do that that machines really
aren't because we have intuition so I
love showing this picture blueberry
muffin or Chihuahua okay so this is kind
of a comical example of where a computer
fails so a lot of these chihuahuas
really do look a lot like a blueberry
muffin I mean this one just tricked me a
little bit but a trained human looking
at this knows for a fact which ones are
which ones are chihuahuas and which ones
are blueberry muffins we just have this
kind of deeper intuition this there's
almost physical intuition of what is
what and that's really more subtle than
what computers have okay so I also like
fried chicken dog I think that's one of
my favorites you know is it a is it a
dog or a fried chicken okay so and
there's tons of examples like this where
you can trick machine learning
classifiers with pretty simple and
obvious misclassifications
but overall image classification is
pretty good and so what people are
moving towards now is more rich scene
classification classification of movies
kind of real-time surveillance of many
many images at many scales so can i you
know in real time from a surveillance
video can i track all of the cars pull
out their license plates can I detect
erratic behavior and what is erratic
behavior well that's hard to quantify
there are outlier events let's say you
know I had the London Underground Metro
platform and everybody rushes in and and
crosses paths and goes their separate
ways can I tell if someone left a piece
of luggage by a support pillar okay
that's a very important surveillance
problem very unstructured very hard so
can you detect something that's out of
the ordinary that's abnormal something
that you should focus your attention on
and get a human to look at okay so
that's becoming the new kind of
difficult level of machine vision
problem creating and analyzing and
classifying movies is a very hard
problem so I think that the YouTube
database is going to be kind of that
next image net database now we have I
don't know millions or billions of hours
of video content and that's an even
vaster data set that we really don't
have the computational power to to do
the full analysis on so that's kind of
where we're gonna have to catch up to in
terms of computational power and this is
extremely important for self-driving
cars for autonomous platforms for drone
surveillance
you know Amazon Prime air is gonna be
flying around drones they need to be
understanding the scene that they're
they're working in self-driving cars are
gonna be driving around they need to
understand what's happening in their
okay so this is I don't know kind of
medium hard we think it's doable but
it's not done yet
image captioning is one of my favorite
examples so this is really neat this is
again one of those problems that even a
few years ago we would have thought like
a computer sure they can classify an
image like dog cat blueberry muffin but
actually making a coherent sentence
describing what they see in a scene that
seemed like a very hard task maybe five
years ago okay and so it's kind of
remarkable how far image captioning has
come this is a great paper I recommend
you you reading another cvpr
from 2015 and you can see in these
images that does a pretty good job man
and black shirt playing guitar
construction worker and orange safety
vest working on road to young girls
playing with Lego toy well I'm not sure
she's a young girl or not but you know
it gets the the gist of the picture
there's a kid playing with LEGOs okay
and it's actually quite good you can
read about the statistics of how
effectively they can and can't label
these scenes and it's really quite
remarkable now there's some comical
examples of when it fails so young boy
holding a baseball bat you know it's
clearly not a cat sitting on a couch
looks more like a ferret to me and this
is my favorite a horse standing in the
middle of the road so no horse but there
is a road okay so so it's it's much
better than we thought it would be just
five years ago but still not perfect
okay so so that's kind of image
classification and unseen classification
and I think I'm gonna go back here for a
minute so so one of the points I like to
make when I talk about image captioning
and classification and surveillance is
do we think where do we think this is
going do we think that the Machine is
going to get better at classifying
scenes are they going to be able to
watch a movie you know Iron Man and
their are they gonna be able to write a
transcript are they going to be able to
write essentially the the script of the
movie just by by watching all of those
scenes evolving in time that's something
that we can't do now with machines but
we're working towards that and so you
have to ask yourself this question
you're thinking about easy medium and
hard also what is possible and what how
feasible is it that this will happen in
the near or long and future okay
and so one of the the kind of baseline
questions I asked myself is can an
average human do this task okay so an
average human yes they can image
classify they can more or less watch a
scene and see kind of track a car or see
if something suspicious happens an
average person can caption an image
pretty accurately and so these are all
examples of something that don't require
extremely specialized you know a
lifetime of skills kind of knowledge to
do and so these are things we think
computers can probably do if they have
enough training data and we have
powerful enough computers and and we try
to tackle it long enough you should also
ask yourself the question are there
hundred billion dollar companies that
care about this problem and for this one
absolutely so that's another thing that
will you know be driving progress in
these fields is is it actually impactful
and important is it something that is
worth doing and is it worth spending
real resources and and human lives
working to solve these problems and so
you know image captioning surveillance
absolutely now there are some tasks
where it does take a long time for
humans to build their expert intuition
but we actually can train machines to do
it if you have enough training data so I
think there are some interesting
examples of medical imaging where it
takes trained humans long times to to
figure out what they're looking at in
these images but with that labeled
images you can essentially transfer that
human experience into into machine
classifiers but then making real
actionable decisions about how to help a
patient improve their health that's
something that's going to take a lot
longer for machines to to do well or at
least we think now maybe in five years
we'll just be blown away with the
performance okay so I'm gonna switch
gears a little bit now we're gonna talk
about actually wrapping this machine
learning so what we've done so far is
just the the the algorithm is kind of
this this brain-in-a-vat or this you
know it's just watching the world and
classifying and annotate
and labeling things so it's kind of not
touching the world it's just observing
and classifying now what I'm going to
talk about is actual control okay so I I
love control theory I think you know if
you're going to model a system if you're
going to build a model you should be
trying to change the system somehow or
oftentimes you're trying to change the
system so for example you know Amazon is
is collecting this data and
understanding how humans decide to buy
things and our preferences but
eventually I think they want us to buy
more stuff and they want us to be
happier when we buy it and to you know
they're essentially trying to manipulate
the system so that you know everybody
benefits that's how that's that's how
that should should hopefully work and so
kind of changing the behavior of the
system so in a self-driving car you're
not just seen classifying you're moving
through this world if I have a robot
walking I'm not just classifying objects
I'm actually interacting with the world
so this is another one of those kind of
amazing topics that that deep learning
has been taking off so this is a 2013
nips paper playing Atari with deep
reinforcement learning so reinforcement
learning is a type of kind of
data-driven experiential control where
you try things you see what happens you
build some estimate of the value of
different actions at different times and
basically people are using the wealth of
data and deep learning to augment this
reinforcement learning for dramatically
improved performance so this is a
classic Atari game
I think it's called breakout and
basically it's kind of like pong you're
moving this thing back and forth trying
to bounce this little red dot and you're
trying to break this rainbow you're
trying to get all of these rainbow
blocks broken okay so this this is kind
of a challenging game after two hours of
playing this game and all it has is the
pixels on the screen and it knows what
its score is after two hours of playing
this game it's pretty good like I don't
think I could play this this effectively
maybe with two hours but I don't think
so this is pretty good but the deep
learning what you really want what the
ultimate goal is this deep reinforcement
learning is the machine not just being
good but learning these the
kind of magic transitions where it goes
from being good to learning the trick
the kind of the secret of the game okay
so the the cheat okay and here you're
gonna see after a couple more hours it
learns the strategy that is much more
effective for winning do you see this
okay so it broke through here and
essentially it just uses the physics of
the game to break all of the the blocks
at once okay so that's the the promise
of this this deep reinforcement learning
is if you if you interact with the
system enough can you actually learn the
rules the physics so that you can find
these these deep exploitations that are
not just you playing the game well but
you being really a master ok and we've
seen you know deep mind google deepmind
is not just playing Atari games they're
playing chess they're playing go and
they're beating the best humans in the
world they're beating hundreds of years
of collected human knowledge and
transferred knowledge now essentially by
playing and learning and adapting their
strategy and finding these deep kind of
exploitations and and physics and
symmetries of these these structured
games and that's really really exciting
so this is one of the more exciting
areas of machine learning research is
kind of deep reinforcement learning ok
another one I love this is this is some
great work in accra 2009 so again please
read this paper this is kind of robotic
reinforcement learning
okay so imitation learning so a human
shows it how to do it a few times maybe
once or twice you can read how many
times and essentially this machine it
has a white background so I'm assuming
it's using video data to figure out
where the position of the blue cup and
the red ball are and after something
like 15 trials it's doing pretty good I
mean like it's getting as close as I
would after fifteen trials probably and
after you know a few dozen trials it's
basically learning the physics that's
refining its control strategy and it's
using this kind of data-driven policy
here so so this is really important this
imitation learning this kind of
reinforcement learning from data from
you know it's using computer vision
to do this is really important for a
number of applications especially things
like manufacturing this is super
important so I saw a talk by someone who
works on this and they said that I think
the anecdote was they had one of their
you know relatives a kid maybe a
twelve-year-old or something try this
game and it took the child about the
same number of trials to learn how to do
this maybe a few less maybe they did it
in 50 trials instead of a hundred but
the same order of magnitude learning
rates here with this robotic arm and
with you know a human child so it's
really remarkable if you think about
automation and manufacturing you know
you have this kind of forward assembly
line model where the same machine is
doing the same task over and over and
over I'm gonna like turn this bolt turn
this bolt turn this bolt that's all that
machine does it was built to do that
forever but in modern manufacturing
maybe I have more customizable designs
maybe I have a robot that has to do
multiple different tasks in one area it
has a work zone this is more like a
skill a skilled worker and so you want
to be able to teach those robots how to
do new tasks quickly and how to transfer
knowledge between one task and another
so this is very exciting
another area that's driving tremendous
research is is robotics and also
self-driving cars so this is kind of a
DARPA competition and DARPA both has
been pushing self-driving cars but also
robots and this is just kind of a funny
video of how bad a lot of these these
robot walking and manipulation tasks are
so we like to see videos of things like
the big dog go Google Boston Dynamics
big dog and you'll see how great our
robotics is now but there are you know
for every success story of robotic
walking or running there's a lot of
failure these things don't have physics
intuition yet they don't have kind of
our degree of control Authority and
actuation and that's something I think
is super important to think about it may
very well be if you think of the science
fiction future of you know 20 30 40
years from now it may very well be that
machines surpass
our ability to pull out patterns and
actionable decisions and and reason
based on data in many many cases and in
high dimensional data but robotic bodies
are not nearly as good as biological
bodies so the fact that I have very
sensitive sensation in my skin I can
feel very minut pressures and frictions
and temperature changes I can feel wind
you know I have I don't know how many
but a ton of different muscle groups
that can work in concert I don't just
have one servo joint okay and so the
fact that you have this this this deep
complexity of sensing and actuation in
biological systems means that I can go
out into the world and gather experience
I can be curious I can try things think
about when you were a kid and you had
something like the ball in the cup you
would just play around with it for hours
and you learn physics and you'd also
learn your own neural motor control
systems and sensing systems and so
robotic systems are really far away in
that sense they don't have a body to
carry them through the world to learn
okay so again I want to change gears a
little bit now so we talked about what
we think is gonna be possible what used
to be hard is now easy in many cases
what's medium hard now we think will be
solved in the future and I want to point
out a couple of cases that I'm gonna go
so it's a little risky making a video in
a field that changes so fast like this
but I'm gonna go on and speculate that
machine learning is not going to write
the next great American novel anytime
soon it'll be classifying and writing
captions of scenes better than we can
maybe but it's not going to write the
next great American novel because that
requires not only a lifetime of
experience but it requires a singular
kind of insight and incentive
experiences and giftedness that is very
rare it can't be replicated these are
these are far far outlier events of
genius and and human skill and intuition
I don't think we're gonna get this
anytime soon so it does beg the question
can you make can you generate other
types of
maybe not the next great American novel
and there is this really cool example by
Botnick studios I love this one they use
machine learning they basically dumped
all of Harry Potter into this learning
algorithm and they tried to generate
their own Harry Potter fanfiction and
it's pretty terrible I mean not know dig
against them it's it's impressive how
good it is considering that I would have
never thought it could even get close I
mean it has complete sentences and some
of the sentences are actually pretty
interesting and pretty you know they
have a little texture they have the
right kind of words and feel other
sentences are just ridiculous and so I
think we're pretty far away from this
kind of generative fiction or generative
paragraphs but you know people are
trying this now and it's pretty
interesting what what people are able to
do in a more kind of serious vein people
I mean this was a while back I guess
2015 a bunch of you know some
researchers at MIT essentially used
machine learning to generate papers
academic papers so you know research
papers for academic academic publication
and they actually faked and got a lot of
these accepted so basically the the
scientific peer-reviewed publishing
system was pretty embarrassing and
letting through these fake papers that
that were just generated kind of by by
an algorithm
okay and so I encourage you to read
about this so this is similar to that
kind of fake news and fake videos and
fake images you can generate things that
pass at least kind of the preliminary BS
detector of professionals in the field
and that's worrisome maybe it says more
about how little time we spend actually
reading papers for review but but I
think it's it's an interesting case
study okay and then I also want us to be
thinking about what is canonically
challenging and what are things that
machine learning probably can't solve or
at least can't completely nail there
there will be fundamental learning
limits for some systems
I think weather prediction is a really
interesting one so weather prediction
there's no doubt that machine learning
and artificial intelligence can and will
and is improving our prediction
capabilities for dynamical systems like
weather and climate but there are hard
information limits this is a chaotic
dynamical system right so everyone's
heard of the butterfly effect a
butterfly flaps its wings in Texas and
it causes a tsunami somewhere else in
the world a month later and that that's
kind of ridiculous I don't think anyone
really you know that's just a soundbite
but there are these sensitive dependence
on initial conditions that do occur in
these complex chaotic dynamical systems
so and what that means is if I don't
measure my system perfectly if there is
like one percent error in my
measurements here my future prediction a
month from now I there might be a
fundamental information limit based on
that uncertainty now amplifying through
this dynamical system I might not be
able to tell where that hurricane is
going to land a month from now or if
it's even going to form so there are
these information theoretic limits for
these chaotic uncertain nonlinear
dynamical systems and that's going to be
very hard for for machine learning to
really move the needle so we actually
need better measurements you need you
know we have mathematical hard
mathematical theory that says for some
prediction problems you just need better
measurements you need more precise
measurements at a finer grade scale and
and then machine learning could
definitely help with the modeling okay
so the last slide I want to show you is
kind of this example just what could go
wrong so I've shown you all of these
great kind of science fiction examples
of robots self-driving cars you know the
computer is gonna label scenes in
and all of this really cool technology
there are some some kind of worrisome
parts of this all right so we should
definitely be thinking what are the
implications of societal surveillance
like when surveillance becomes cheap and
easy when would my phone can just listen
to everything I say and parse it into
text and then make decisions based on
that when we have video surveillance
watching everything how is that going to
change the world is it going to be a
better place obviously there will be
some good things about it but there will
be some bad things this is what all
technology is like this is just a very
kind of digestible example of this right
so in an Amazon cart you know I buy a
calculus book it maybe suggests hey you
might want a differential equations book
or a physics textbook write calculus
based physics so it suggests what goes
also with those objects there have been
cases where people have wanted to buy
one good and the the learning algorithm
this is based on data this is based on
historical patterns of shoppers
presumably it has suggested the parts to
make dangerous devices like you know I
mean this looks like we're making
thermite okay so that's pretty worrisome
that I go and I want to buy art
materials and this algorithm is telling
me hey maybe you should make thermite
okay
this isn't like this was a malicious
algorithm or someone was trying to to be
destructive but algorithms are only as
good as the data you're training on the
historical data and that's pretty
worrisome that the historical data is
saying hey make dangerous devices this
is also a huge a huge issue if you are
using machine learning for something
like hiring people if your corporation
has historically made hiring decisions
that are biased then you don't want to
train your algorithm on who are the best
people to train because you might get
this biased workforce in the future also
this is also an issue with you know
machine learning for who to give parole
to or who to give who to where how to
set bail right so these are actual case
studies people are doing right now
is you know can we use machine learning
to help take some of the burden off of
overburdened judges for setting bail for
parole for things like that but if you
have a historically biased set of
training data if one segment of the
population has been getting a biased
treatment as if it hasn't been
historically fair you have to be very
careful using that data for future
inference and model building or else you
run the risk of baking that bias into
into the structure of your learning and
so blindly trusting the output of these
algorithms basing these on historical
data you know there's huge ethical and
societal issues that we have to
understand so that's that's hard okay so
easy medium and hard I really think
that's one of the hardest issues we we
face okay
so that's that's basically it I just
kind of wanted to give you this high
level kind of fun overview of what is
currently easy medium and hard what is
hard now you know may be easy in the
future and vice-versa but really machine
learning and artificial intelligence
it's undeniable this is changing the
world it's changing what's possible in
transportation and health in
manufacturing in you know ad placement
basically everything where we have big
data and we have hard problems where
we're starting as a community to build
these machine learning and artificial
intelligence systems now things that
will move the needle in the future I
think you know of course better
computers and better algorithms that's
that's a given more data more investment
we're investing tremendously in this
world we're you know this is kind of the
space race we're all pushing towards
these better artificial intelligence
systems across the board
what will essentially one of the things
that I think will move the needle is
understanding physics so image
classification if you know if you
remember like the facial recognition it
got better when it understood the
physics that faces are not 2d but they
live on a three-dimensional skeleton
they live on a skull okay so that that's
an example of physics what I'm going to
call physics are the rules of the system
and so humans and biological systems are
math
stirrers of understanding abstractly and
in a hierarchical fuzzy way the rules of
the system and using that to improve our
learning rates and to assimilate new
data more rapidly and so I think that's
going to be a transformative piece of
this this kind of developing machine
learning and AI is how do we how do we
bake in physics that we know how do we
how do we teach the computer F equals MA
and there's conservation of mass and
energy and momentum so that we can get
faster learning rates with less data how
do we extract unknown physics from these
systems if I if I just showed a machine
learning algorithm a video of the night
sky for weeks and weeks can it learn the
planetary orbits can it learn that there
are stars and planets and that they're
different can it learn F equals MA can
it do what Newton did I mean we're not
there yet we're not even close okay but
extracting those symmetries and
conservation laws and unknown physics
from data you know that's something I'm
personally very excited about it's
relevant for self-driving cars it's
relevant for robots walking I think it's
relevant for image classification
because what is an image but you know a
measurement of photons interacting with
the physical world okay so so I think
that's going to move the needle you know
as much as volumes of data and better
algorithms and better computers okay I
hope I hope you're excited it's gonna be
an interesting world you should watch
this again in five years and laugh at
what I said was gonna be hard and how
easy it is okay thank you